[HOST]: 哎，Mira，我最近看到一个数据，把我吓到了。你知道现在一个晶体管多少钱吗？
[MIRA]: 嗯，多少钱？
[HOST]: 大概是一九七零年价格的五十亿分之一。五十亿分之一啊。我当时看到这个数字，脑子里第一反应是，科技进步真的太疯狂了。
[MIRA]: 对，半导体的成本下降曲线确实是人类工业史上最夸张的故事之一。每隔一两年翻一倍的性能，成本还在往下掉。你看到这个数字会觉得，哇，这就是指数增长的力量嘛。
[HOST]: 对，但是我紧接着就看到了另一个数字。美国住宅建筑的每平方英尺造价，扣除通胀之后，比五十年前还贵。还贵啊！我就觉得哪里不对劲了。
[MIRA]: 嗯，你抓到了一个特别关键的对比。两个行业，都吸引了大量的资本和人才，但一个成本降了十万倍，另一个反而涨了。这不是小数点的差异，这是两个方向完全相反的趋势。
[HOST]: 对啊，而且你想想看嘛，盖房子这件事，我们也不是没在努力。预制房屋都搞了一百年了，各种新技术，新材料也一直在出。日本甚至把建筑管制放开得比任何西方国家都彻底。结果呢？成本还是在涨。
[MIRA]: 没错，这就是让我觉得一般的解释不够用的原因。你去问大多数人为什么盖房子越来越贵，他们会说，监管太多啊，邻避效应啊，劳动力成本高啊，研发投入不够啊。这些因素都是真的，但你把每一个都解决了，曲线还是不动。日本的例子就证明了这一点。
[HOST]: 等一下，让我消化一下。你的意思是说，这不是某一个行业的个别问题？
[MIRA]: 对，这是一个结构性的分界线。有一些行业天生就能享受指数级的成本下降，而另一些行业天生就不可以。不管你投多少钱，派多少聪明人去做。问题不是谁更努力，问题是，为什么有些行业能坐上指数增长的快车，而另一些行业连门票都买不到。
[HOST]: 哇，这个问题一提出来，我就知道这集值得聊了。那你在文章里给出的答案是什么？这条分界线到底画在哪里？
[MIRA]: 我的答案是，这条线画在一个你可能没想到的地方。不是数字和实体的区别，不是有没有监管的区别，甚至不是公共和私营的区别。是一个来自语言哲学的老概念。类型和个例的区别。听起来很学术对吧？但我接下来会解释，为什么这个区分能预测几乎所有行业的成本走向。
[HOST]: 好，我已经被勾住了。但是先别急着讲类型和个例，我想先搞清楚一个更基础的问题。指数级的成本下降，它到底需要什么条件？你在文章里用了一个词叫工厂逻辑。
[MIRA]: 对，我管它叫工厂逻辑。不是说一定要有一个实体的工厂，而是说，能产生指数成本下降的行业，它们都满足跟工厂一样的条件。一共四个条件。
[HOST]: 嗯，好，一个一个来。
[MIRA]: 第一个，输入相同。就是说，你造第一个和造第一百万个，用的原材料是一样的。第二个，过程可复制。你造第一百万个的时候，用的方法跟造第一个是一样的。
[HOST]: 嗯，嗯，这两个好理解。第三个呢？
[MIRA]: 第三个，学习曲线可以传递。就是你在造第一百个的时候学到的经验，可以直接用到第一百零一个上。你每次做，都在积累有效的经验，这些经验不会浪费。
[HOST]: 嗯，嗯嗯，第四个？
[MIRA]: 第四个，输出接口可以标准化。就是你造出来的东西，可以直接插到下一个系统里去用，不用每次都去谈判，去适配。
[HOST]: 让我用自己的话总结一下啊。就是说，材料一样，方法一样，经验可以叠加，产出能直接对接。四个条件都满足，成本就能指数下降？
[MIRA]: 对，这就是赖特定律的核心。赖特定律说的是，累计产量每翻一倍，成本就会下降一个固定的百分比。这个规律在半导体，太阳能电池板，锂电池，基因组测序这些领域都被验证过了。曲线之稳定，你甚至可以只用累计产量来预测未来的成本。
[HOST]: 等等，赖特定律，这个我得问一下。跟摩尔定律是什么关系？
[MIRA]: 好问题。摩尔定律说的是芯片上的晶体管数量大概每两年翻一倍，这是关于性能的。赖特定律更通用，它说的是任何产品，只要累计产量翻倍，单位成本就会按一个固定比例下降。摩尔定律是赖特定律在半导体领域的一个特例。赖特定律适用的范围更广。
[HOST]: 明白了。那反过来说，四个条件里只要有一个不满足，指数就停了？
[MIRA]: 对，哪怕只有一个条件断裂，整个加速机制就失效了。我们拿建筑来说。每一块地都不一样，土壤不一样，坡度不一样，隔壁邻居的挡土墙不一样，当地的消防法规不一样。所以第一个条件，输入相同，就不满足。
[HOST]: 嗯，这个很直观。每栋房子面对的情况都是独特的。
[MIRA]: 再看医疗。每个病人都不一样，所以治疗过程永远不可能完全复制。你上一个病人用的方案，下一个病人可能完全不适用。第二个条件就断了。
[HOST]: 嗯，教育呢？
[MIRA]: 教育更有意思。每个学生卡住的地方都不一样。这个学生在这个概念上的困惑，跟下一个学生完全不同。所以你教上一个学生的经验，很难直接搬到下一个学生身上。第三个条件，学习曲线的传递，就漏了。
[HOST]: 哎，你这么一列出来，我突然觉得，建筑，医疗，教育，这不就是我们日常生活中最贵的几样东西吗？
[MIRA]: 对吧！这就是问题的核心。我们最想降低成本的那些领域，恰恰是指数增长最难发挥作用的领域。但在解释为什么之前，我想先引入一个更根本的区分。
[HOST]: 嗯，就是你说的类型和个例？
[MIRA]: 对。这个概念最早来自语言哲学。简单说，类型就是一个可以产生完全相同实例的类别。个例就是一个特定的，具体的发生。
[HOST]: 嗯，有点抽象，能举个例子吗？
[MIRA]: 当然。你想想英文里面the这个词。the作为一个词条，它是一个类型。但你在一本书里看到的每一个the，每一次它被印出来，那就是一个个例。所有个例都是完全一样的。它们都是同一个类型的完美复制品。
[HOST]: 噢，就是说，类型是那个模板，个例是每一次的复制？
[MIRA]: 可以这么理解。但关键在于，有些东西天生就是类型的。你编译好一个软件，每一份拷贝都跟其他拷贝完全一样。这个软件就是类型。你设计一次，可以无限部署。每次部署都是完美的实例。
[HOST]: 嗯，嗯嗯。
[MIRA]: 但一栋建筑呢？这栋楼，建在这块地上，面对这种土质，配合这个分区规划的特殊许可，考虑隔壁那堵挡土墙，遵守这个城市的消防法规。这栋楼就是一个个例。它被设计一次，建造一次。下一栋楼在下一块地上，虽然可能共用一些部件和方法，但整体的组装，设计和场地的整合，这个过程是独特的。
[HOST]: 我懂了。就是说，你没办法找另一栋楼来替代这一栋，因为在最重要的那个层面上，根本不存在另一栋一模一样的楼。
[MIRA]: 你说得特别准确。这就是关键机制。工厂逻辑之所以能在类型产品上持续叠加，是因为每一个单位真的跟上一个完全一样。你造第一百万个芯片学到的东西，百分之百适用于第一百万零一个。但如果你的产出是个例的，你治疗上一个病人学到的经验，只能部分地用到下一个病人身上。因为下一个病人在医学上的相关特征，有一部分是独特的。学习曲线在漏。
[HOST]: 学习曲线在漏，这个说法太形象了。就像你往一个有洞的桶里倒水，你确实在倒，但存不住。
[MIRA]: 对，而且这不是一个程度问题。这是一个相变。
[HOST]: 嗯，相变？你是说像水变成冰那种？
[MIRA]: 嗯，就是那种质的跳变。一个产品要么是可替代的，就是说一个实例可以替换另一个实例而不损失任何东西，要么就不是。没有中间状态。指数增长只在可替代的那一边发生。在另一边，你最多只能获得线性的改善。
[HOST]: 线性改善是什么意思？就是一点一点地慢慢变好？
[MIRA]: 对，就是每年进步一点点。不像指数增长那种，今年降一半，明年再降一半。而且往往你连线性改善都得不到。你会遇到一个叫鲍莫尔成本病的东西。
[HOST]: 嗯，鲍莫尔成本病？这是什么？
[MIRA]: 这是经济学家威廉，鲍莫尔提出的一个概念。简单说就是，在那些生产力很难提升的领域，成本会不断上涨。为什么呢？因为那些生产力可以快速提升的领域，比如科技行业，把工资推高了。你在个例领域工作的人，比如老师，护士，建筑工人，他们的生产力没有指数增长，但他们的工资得跟上整个社会的水平，不然就招不到人了。
[HOST]: 哦！所以个例领域的成本上升，某种程度上是被类型领域的成本下降给拉上去的？
[MIRA]: 就是这个意思。类型领域越是高歌猛进，个例领域越显得昂贵。这不是因为个例领域变差了，而是因为相对差距在拉大。
[HOST]: 这真的是一个特别反直觉的洞察。让我想想，就是说科技越进步，我们看病，上学，买房反而感觉越贵？
[MIRA]: 感觉越贵，而且实际上相对来说确实越贵。这不是错觉。这是结构性的。
[HOST]: 好，那我想用具体的例子来验证一下你这个框架。建筑这个例子你刚才已经提了一点，能展开说说吗？
[MIRA]: 建筑是一个特别好的检验案例。因为它表面上看起来应该能有指数增长的。你看，预制构件，木头框架，桁架，石膏板，这些都是类型产品。它们确实在变便宜。
[HOST]: 对啊，那为什么整栋房子的成本没有跟着降下来呢？
[MIRA]: 因为把这些构件组装成一栋具体的房子，这个过程是个例工作。你得处理这块地的具体情况，这个坡度怎么打地基，这个邻居的排水怎么避开，这个城市的法规怎么满足。这些事情每次都不一样。所以类型层面的成本降低，被个例层面的成本给吸收掉了。
[HOST]: 嗯，就像预制板确实便宜了，但把它装上去的人工和协调成本没降。
[MIRA]: 没错。这也解释了为什么预制房屋搞了一百年，从来没有产生过指数级的成本下降。类型部件在变便宜，但个例的整合永远不会按指数下降。
[HOST]: 好，那医疗呢？我记得你在文章里说医疗沿着这条线分裂得很干净？
[MIRA]: 特别干净。你看医学影像诊断，比如CT扫描的读片。同样的算法处理每一张片子，输出的是一个分类结果。这是类型操作。它确实在变得越来越便宜，越来越准确。
[HOST]: 嗯，这个我有感觉。现在A I读片已经很厉害了。
[MIRA]: 对。但你再看整个看诊过程呢。医生要理解这个病人的病史，要做鉴别诊断，要考虑这个病人的其他疾病，这个病人的保险情况，然后制定治疗方案。每一次看诊都是独特配置的。这是个例工作。
[HOST]: 所以影像变便宜了，但看一次病的钱没变少？
[MIRA]: 你去看统计数据就会发现，影像成本确实在降，但整体医疗支出一直在涨。类型层在变便宜，但个例层把省下来的钱全吃掉了。
[HOST]: 这让我想到一个事情。很多人说A I要颠覆医疗，要让医疗成本大幅下降。你怎么看？
[MIRA]: 其实吧，我在文章里给了一个具体的预测。A I在放射科的诊断准确率，五年之内会超过普通的人类放射科医生。医学影像的成本会大幅下降。但是，整体的医疗支出不会因此减少。
[HOST]: 嗯，不会减少？为什么？
[MIRA]: 因为省下来的钱会被个例层吸收掉。护理协调，治疗决策，针对具体病人的方案规划，这些都是个例工作。A I可以特别强大，但只要输出必须针对一个特定的案例来定制，这个定制的成本就不会按指数下降。
[HOST]: 哎，这让我有点沮丧啊。就是说A I再厉害，医疗也不会变便宜？
[MIRA]: 怎么说呢，不是完全不变。而是变化的方式跟大家预期的不一样。A I不会带来整体的指数成本下降，它会带来一个层级分离。类型层会变得极其便宜，个例层还是贵。成本的占比会变，但总的成本不会崩塌式下降。
[HOST]: 嗯，你这么一说，我突然觉得，对教育这个领域也适用吧？
[MIRA]: 特别适用。你看在线课程的发展就知道了。课程内容，教科书，教学视频，这些是类型产品。教科书的价格在数字化之后急剧下降，视频课程可以无限扩展。
[HOST]: 对，现在好多免费课程，质量还很高。
[MIRA]: 没错。但你看大规模在线公开课，就是MOOC。
[HOST]: 嗯，MOOC是什么？
[MIRA]: 就是那些网上可以免费上的大学课程。你可能听说过Coursera或者edX。它们把名校的课程视频放到网上，几百万人可以同时看。听起来很完美对吧？
[HOST]: 嗯，对啊，教育民主化，多好的事。
[MIRA]: 但你猜它们的完成率是多少？大概在百分之五到百分之十五之间。
[HOST]: 嗯，这么低？真的假的？
[MIRA]: 真的。为什么呢？因为MOOC完美地扩展了类型层，就是课程内容。但它完全剥掉了个例层。什么是个例层呢？就是教学关系。这个学生，在这个时刻，对这个概念的困惑。这是独特的。你可以免费分发讲座视频，但你没办法免费分发家教。
[HOST]: 你可以免费分发视频，但没办法免费分发家教。这句话说得太好了。
[MIRA]: 其实吧，这就是整个教育科技行业过去十年的核心困境。大家一直在尝试把个例的教学过程变成类型的产品，但没有成功。因为这不是努力的问题，是产出的结构决定了它做不到。
[HOST]: 好，那我想问一个可能有点挑衅的问题啊。你不是说这个分界线不是按数字和实体来划的吗？但半导体，软件确实都是类型产品，而建筑，医疗确实都涉及实体世界。你怎么证明这不是数字和实体的区别？
[MIRA]: 好问题。你看太阳能电池板。太阳能电池板是百分之百的实体产品，硅，玻璃，金属框架。但它是类型产品。每一块板子都是同一个设计的完美实例。所以太阳能的成本曲线跟半导体一样，是指数下降的。
[HOST]: 嗯，嗯。
[MIRA]: 再看药片。一颗药，它是一个化学分子。完完全全的实体产品。但一旦这个分子被发现了，每一颗药都是一样的。它是类型。所以药品生产的成本也是可以指数下降的。当然发现新药的过程不是，那是另一回事。
[HOST]: 哦，所以实体产品也可以骑上指数增长的快车，只要它是类型的？
[MIRA]: 没错。锂电池也是一样，每一个电芯都是同一个设计的实例。基因组测序也是，同一套流程处理每一个样本。这些全是实体操作，但它们都是类型产品，所以它们的成本曲线全是指数下降的。
[HOST]: 明白了。所以关键真的不是数字还是实体，而是你的产品能不能被完美复制。
[MIRA]: 准确地说，是你的产出能不能被替代。一个实例能不能无损地替换另一个实例。如果可以，你就在指数增长的这一边。如果不可以，你就不在。
[HOST]: 这也解释了为什么那么多人预测A I会颠覆一切，但实际上可能不会？
[MIRA]: 说实话，这正是我写这篇文章的核心动机之一。现在有太多关于A I的预测是笼统的，说什么A I会让一切成本趋近于零。但如果你用类型和个例的框架来看，就会发现A I的影响是有结构的，不是均匀的。
[HOST]: 嗯，怎么说？
[MIRA]: A I进入个例领域的时候，它的收益会集中在那些个例领域里面的类型层。比如在医疗里，A I可以极大地降低读片的成本，因为读片是类型操作。但它很难降低整个看诊的成本，因为看诊的核心是个例工作。
[HOST]: 等一下，我想把这个说得更清楚一点。你的意思是，每个所谓的个例领域，其实里面都有一些类型的子层和一些个例的子层？
[MIRA]: 对对对，就是这样。任何一个复杂的领域都不是纯粹的类型或者纯粹的个例。它是混合的。医疗里面，影像分析是类型层，临床判断是个例层。教育里面，课程内容是类型层，师生互动是个例层。建筑里面，预制构件是类型层，现场组装是个例层。
[HOST]: 那A I做的事情就是把类型层的成本打下来？
[MIRA]: 对，而且可以打得很低。但个例层不动。所以整体的效果不是什么指数级的全面成本崩塌。而是一个很戏剧性的从新分配，成本集中到了个例层上。便宜的部分变得极便宜，贵的部分还是贵。比例在变，但那个豁免还在。
[HOST]: 你说的豁免，就是文章标题里的那个概念？
[MIRA]: 对，我叫它指数豁免。就是个例领域天然地免于指数成本下降。这不是因为我们不够聪明，不是因为投入不够，是因为产出的结构不允许。
[HOST]: 你刚才提到了法律行业，能说说吗？
[MIRA]: 法律是另一个很典型的例子。你看文件审查和案例研究，这些是类型操作。A I可以在几分钟内做完一个律师团队几周才能做完的文件审查。成本会断崖式下降。
[HOST]: 嗯，那诉讼成本会降吗？
[MIRA]: 我的预测是不会。因为庭审准备和法庭上的判断，是个例工作。每个案子的具体情况不一样，每个法官的风格不一样，每个陪审团的构成不一样。这些不是你可以用同一个模板去处理的。文件审查变便宜了，但诉讼成本可能纹丝不动。
[HOST]: 诶，这个预测挺大胆的。如果未来真的是这样，那很多人对A I的期待可能要落空了啊。
[MIRA]: 怎么说呢，不是落空，是需要调整预期。A I确实会带来巨大的变化，但变化的形状跟很多人想的不一样。它不是一个均匀的浪潮，把所有领域的成本都冲低。它更像是，在每个领域里面，把能压缩的那些层极致压缩，然后让那些不能压缩的层暴露出来。
[HOST]: 让不能压缩的层暴露出来。这个说法很有意思。就像退潮之后你才能看到礁石在哪里。
[MIRA]: 对，我觉得这个比喻很好。A I就是那个退潮。它会让我们清楚地看到，每个行业里面，真正贵的，真正难的，真正不可替代的部分在哪里。
[HOST]: 那我想问一个更大的问题。如果你这个框架是对的，对于我们最想解决的那些问题，医疗，教育，住房，法律，我们应该怎么想？
[MIRA]: 这是一个我也在思考的问题，说实话，我没有一个完美的答案。但我觉得第一步是诚实地面对这个边界条件。这些行业贵，不是因为有人在做错事，不是因为监管太多或者创新太少。是因为它们的产出结构是个例的。
[HOST]: 嗯，嗯。
[MIRA]: 当你认识到这一点，你就不会再期待一个银弹了。你不会觉得某一项新技术，不管是A I还是区块链还是别的什么，能突然把医疗成本砍到十分之一。因为这不是技术问题，是几何问题。
[HOST]: 嗯，几何问题，你指的是？
[MIRA]: 产出的几何结构。你的产品能不能被完美复制，这是由你的产品的本质决定的，不是由你用什么技术生产它决定的。你不能通过更聪明的方法把一个个例变成一个类型，因为让它成为个例的，恰恰是那些让它对具体的人有价值的特征。
[HOST]: 哇，等一下。你再说一遍最后那句？
[MIRA]: 让一个产出成为个例的，恰恰是那些让它对具体的人有价值的特征。这个病人跟那个病人不一样，这不是一个bug，这是医疗的根本前提。这个学生跟那个学生不一样，这不是教育的低效之处，这是教育存在的意义。
[HOST]: 这真的让我从新理解了很多事情。就是说，个例性不是需要被解决的问题，它本身就是价值所在。
[MIRA]: 没错。你可以给它们中间的类型层降成本，这是好的。让影像更便宜，让课程免费，让文件审查自动化。这些都很有价值。但你不能指望把整个领域的成本压到接近零。因为你不能把每个人的独特性压缩掉。
[HOST]: 那回到A I公司。很多A I公司在融资的时候会说，我们要用A I颠覆医疗，颠覆教育，颠覆法律。你觉得他们是在说谎，还是在自欺欺人？
[MIRA]: 其实吧，我觉得大部分不是在说谎。他们是真的相信指数增长可以不受限制地延伸到所有领域。因为他们来自类型领域。他们在软件行业，在芯片行业，见惯了指数增长的奇迹。所以他们本能地觉得，只要技术够强，一切都可以指数化。
[HOST]: 嗯，但你说不可以。
[MIRA]: 不可以。你不能扩展不能被复制的东西。这不是技术限制，是逻辑限制。就像你不能通过跑得更快来变成两个人一样。速度的问题和数量的问题是两回事。
[HOST]: 哈哈，这个比喻好。不能通过跑得更快来变成两个人。
[MIRA]: 但我想强调，我不是说A I没用。A I在这些领域里面可以做的事情是真的很多。它可以把类型层的成本打到极低。它可以释放出人类专家的精力，让他们专注在真正需要个例判断的地方。这本身就是巨大的价值。
[HOST]: 嗯，对，只是期待需要校准。
[MIRA]: 对。你不要指望A I让看病变成跟搜索一样免费。但你可以期待A I让医生把更多时间花在跟你对话，理解你的具体情况上，而不是在看片子。那个对话本身，那个个例化的判断，还是要花钱的。可能永远都要花钱。
[HOST]: 你知道吗，Mira，我现在脑子里有一个画面。就好像每个行业都是一座冰山。水面上的部分，就是类型层，A I可以快速把它融掉。但水面下的部分，个例层，它就在那里，你看不到它变小。
[MIRA]: 而且啊，水面上的部分融掉之后，水面下的部分看起来反而更大了。因为它占总成本的比例提高了。
[HOST]: 对！所以A I越成功，个例工作反而显得越贵？
[MIRA]: 就是鲍莫尔成本病的另一种表现。A I把能自动化的部分全自动化了，剩下来的，那些必须由人来做个例判断的部分，变成了整个体系里最贵的瓶颈。你会觉得，怎么A I都这么厉害了，看个病还是这么贵？就是因为真正贵的那个部分，A I碰不到。
[HOST]: 让我想到另一个问题。现在有很多人担心A I会取代各种工作。按照你的框架，应该怎么理解？
[MIRA]: 如果你的工作主要是类型操作，比如标准化的文件审查，常规的数据分析，反复性的诊断，那确实面临很大的替代压力。但如果你的工作的核心是个例判断，是面对一个独特的情况做出适合这个情况的决策，那A I更多的是工具，而不是替代。
[HOST]: 所以关键是看你做的是类型的事还是个例的事。
[MIRA]: 没错。而且很多工作其实是混合的。一个医生百分之三十的时间在做类型工作，比如看片子，查数据。百分之七十在做个例工作，比如跟病人沟通，做临床判断。A I会吃掉那百分之三十，但让那百分之七十变得更高效，而不是消失。
[HOST]: 嗯，这比那些简单地说A I会取代多少多少工作的预测，要精确得多。
[MIRA]: 我觉得大部分关于A I影响的预测之所以不准确，就是因为它们没有区分类型和个例。它们把一个行业当作一个整体来判断，A I能不能取代它。但实际上你应该把每个行业拆开，看它里面的类型层和个例层分别是什么，A I能影响哪个层，不能影响哪个层。
[HOST]: 好的。那我们来到最后一个问题吧。你在文章的最后一句说，指数豁免不是一个需要被解决的问题，它是一个边界条件。个例不会复合增长。你能给我们的听众解释一下，这句话对他们意味着什么？
[MIRA]: 意味着我们需要接受一件事情。有些东西注定是昂贵的，因为它对你的价值恰恰来自于它是为你量身定制的。你的教育不是流水线产品。你的医疗不是标准件。你住的房子不是从目录里挑出来的。它们贵，是因为它们是你的。
[HOST]: 嗯，嗯。
[MIRA]: 我觉得真正有用的态度不是愤怒，不是说凭什么这些东西不能便宜。而是理解这个结构，然后在这个结构里面做更明智的选择。把类型层能省的钱全省下来，把省下来的资源用在个例层上。不要在错误的层去追求错误的效率。
[HOST]: 不要在错误的层去追求错误的效率。这句话可以当座右铭了。
[MIRA]: 哈，谢谢。不过我其实也还在想这个问题。有些东西我也不确定。比如A I会不会有一天强大到可以处理真正的个例判断？我文章里说的是不会，因为产出结构决定了。但说实话，我对自己这个判断也只有大概七八成的信心。
[HOST]: 你刚才说七八成信心，那剩下的两三成在想什么？
[MIRA]: 在想，如果有一天A I能够真正理解个例的每一个独特面向，能够把每一次个例判断都做到跟人类专家一样好，那会怎么样。从技术上来说，也许有可能。但即使做到了，成本结构也不一定会变。因为处理个例判断需要的计算量和注意力，可能本身就不能按指数缩减。
[HOST]: 因为每个个例都需要独立的处理，你没办法批量化？
[MIRA]: 对。这就像，哪怕你请了一个全世界最聪明的家教，他一次也只能教一个学生。他可以教得更好，但他不能同时教一百万个学生，因为每个学生需要的东西不一样。智能解决质量问题，但不解决数量问题。而指数成本下降需要的是数量上的可复制性。
[HOST]: 智能解决质量问题，但不解决数量问题。好，我觉得这是一个特别好的地方来结束今天的对话。最后给听众留一个问题吧？
[MIRA]: 好。下次你觉得某个行业太贵，太落后，不够创新的时候，试着问自己一个问题。它提供给你的东西，是可以被另一份完全相同的东西替代的，还是说，正是因为它是专门为你的情况定制的，你才需要它？如果答案是后者，那这个行业可能不是在做错什么。它只是在做一件天生不会变便宜的事情。然后你可以想想，在你自己的工作和生活里，哪些是类型的，哪些是个例的。你真正稀缺的，真正有价值的贡献，在哪一边。
[HOST]: 哇。好，今天就到这里。谢谢Mira。
[MIRA]: 嗯，谢谢你，聊得特别开心。
[HOST]: 各位听众，我们下期再见。如果今天这集对你有启发，欢迎分享给朋友。特别是那些在建筑，医疗，教育行业工作的朋友，我觉得他们会有很多共鸣。
[MIRA]: 对，也欢迎来Substack留言告诉我你们的看法。我真的很想知道，在你们各自的行业里，类型层和个例层的分界线画在哪里。
[HOST]: 嗯，好，下期见。